you know I really feel bad for anyone
who canceled their HBO after Game of
Thrones rap and they were like don't
need it anymore no you do if you still
have it great here you go if you don't
have it reactivated cuz I'm gonna tell
you about something you should probably
watch so Chernobyl is an HBO miniseries
about five episodes long and it's the
story of the great true noble disaster
of 1986 in the USSR there was a nuclear
power plant and the core of that plant
exploded that's just bad news all around
lots of radiation lots of contamination
lots of death a lot of people got hurt a
lot of people died it was enormous and
that's what this show really illustrates
is the enormity of all of it the pilot
episode of Chernobyl is one of the most
captivating pilot episodes of anything
I've ever watched it brings you right in
but I want to say right now Chernobyl's
not it's not an action movie or anything
like that it's not like ooh the big
power plant exploding oh gotta get Bruce
Willis in there to fix it it's not like
that and this thing I really love about
this it always knew that it was like
people affected by this if they lived
through it are still alive they're still
affected their families are affected
their children are affected and it
doesn't go true noble Diaries and say
well [ __ ] it - all of it will just make
a horror movie or something this feels
very real it's very informative and
that's what Jared Harris alright let's
just get right into it before I talk
about how informative this show is Jared
Harris is so good he's one of my
favorites he's always so great even if
Jared Harris is in a movie that's not
good he automatically elevates the movie
at least the scenes he's in he's got to
get something for this he's that good
and there are a few scenes were his
character which I shouldn't call a
character he's portraying a real person
and a big part of the show is his legacy
but there are a few scenes were they
have to break down like we're not
nuclear physicists but they have to
break down to the audience what fission
is what a nuclear reactor does what
radiation does like I know about
radiation because radiation has always
scared me cuz at one point for some odd
reason when I was in the single digits
of age like I don't know five to nine my
dad was like hey watch that movie the
day after and then on just radiation
scared the living [ __ ] out of me so I
kind of know what radiation does but
they did just do simple breakdowns at
the end of these breakdown model
you get what fission is what nuclear
reactors do what radiation does of the
human body you know that phrase if you
can't explain it to a kid you don't
really understand it this show can
explain it to a kid though kids should
not watch this show this show is graphic
the show is very real stellan skarsgård
is great too it's just the dynamic
between stellan skarsgård and jared
harris
i just i loved the two of them together
at first they don't like each other very
much and they kind of grow as comrades
as friends as colleagues trying to
tackle this thing that's another thing
this show does very well it's like this
disaster was so big it illustrates how
big it was and you really feel like
everyone involved you see them how they
probably saw themselves as ants like if
you were Titans or gods we can just take
a volcano lava and just pour it over the
plant and be like it's done but we're
not we're just little human beings and
the problem is just too big but you got
to solve it you have to there's no other
way and whereas the pilot episode is
captivating in that disaster sense the
next couple episodes they're captivating
in a very different way a very
informative way like it's always a
problem it's like this is the problem
how do we solve that problem how do we
fix it I don't know we have to figure it
out episode threes rough though like
that's the point when people with a lot
of radiation sickness who had a lot of
exposure their bodies are showing it and
the makeup the effects holy [ __ ] I've
never seen it done this well just movie
TV shows radiation poisoning has never
looked this real it's rough I'm just
saying if you can get past episode 3 you
can get through the entire miniseries
but when there's a scenario like that
and people actually did suffer like that
and you're doing a miniseries or movie
to show it you have to show that graphic
nature of it otherwise you're not doing
the victims the justice or a service
you're just letting people go okay it
was only so bad and the effective
storytelling and showing the enormity of
all of it isn't just in the clean if
there's one scene where it's like
alright these people have to go into
where this water is it's basically a
water pipe maze and their Geiger
counters are just screaming at them
you're like just just get out just get
out if I can't they got to do their job
because if they don't do the job they're
down there to do a lot more people are
gonna die it's it's oh my god those
first couple episodes
the tension building a lot of movies out
there can take a lot of notes from
Chernobyl about tension building the
sound of a Geiger counter you know that
sound I hate it
it's just it freaks me out and a big
theme in this show arguably the biggest
theme is how lack of information or
manipulation of information just leads
to bad thing just leads to people
getting hurt people dying cuz it was the
height of the Cold War the USSR was like
you know we're tough we don't make
mistakes and then disaster happened even
after the disaster no no it's not that
bad and it was much worse than they were
saying it was and I'm not saying that's
just a Cold War USSR trait every country
on Earth at all
every government can learn something
from that lesson an informed society
might not be the best thing for the
government but it's the best thing for
the people the government serves so the
episode breakdown is episode 1
captivating as hell it's a captivating
tragic disaster episode essentially the
next three episodes are the enormity of
the cleanup procedure and process in the
final episode is essentially a
captivating court episode all of it
lines up together to give you a very
effective telling of this tragedy great
acting great storytelling great tone
eerie music to go along with the tone it
entertains you and they never lose sight
of the fact that they're treading very
delicate water here I personally feel
that this Chernobyl miniseries was the
perfect mix of entertainment information
justice in tribute like it just all of
it lined up to make something that's
kind of a rarity and entertainment long
story short Chernobyl the HBO miniseries
is awesome tacular
or so Chernobyl have you seen it watch
it you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]